thanks for coming it's gonna be a good
talk I think you're gonna like it it's
gonna be fun I'm really happy to be back
here it's my second time in Malmo I was
here the last time I was here the
Eurovision was here I don't know if you
recall I was a few years ago it was a
lot calmer in the city this time around
then it was the last time it was a lot
of fun I'm gonna tell you a story this
afternoon about lean agile and Design
Thinking my background is in design I've
been doing a lot of work in the agile
space doing a lot of work in the lean
startup space over the years and I've
seen a lot of of the attempts to make
these ideas work well together I'm gonna
share some of those ideas with you today
give you some things to take home some
practical tips that you can use
hopefully to make your team's be more
successful build better products satisfy
your customers needs and ultimately
build better businesses that's the goal
but to get started I want to tell you a
story about my favorite movie always a
good place to start my favorite movie is
Goodfellas how many of you have not seen
Goodfellas I don't have that kind of
time we don't have two hours to sit here
and watch it and then talk about
although we sure that'd be a great
presentation
Goodfellas if you don't know it's one of
the quintessential kind of American
gangster movies right
fantastic movie with an amazing cast and
great lines there's it's a movie filled
with great scenes and great dialogue but
this is my favorite scene in the movie
now you have most of you haven't seen
the movies which is kind of so I'm gonna
spoil a little scene for you just one
one tiny bit of the movie so what's
happening in this scene so this is um
you've got Robert De Niro obviously
you've got Ray Liotta there on the left
and you've got Joe Pesci there to the
right of Ray Liotta now they're
gangsters and they have a problem and
it's in the back of ray Liotta's car
that's where the problem is and they're
stopping in late at night to Joe Pesci's
mom's house that's Joe Pesci's mom to
pick up a knife a big butcher knife that
they need to solve the problem that's in
the back of ray Liotta's car that's
what's happening in the scene now it's
late at night they stopped in
and she wakes up it's an Italian
household she says no no you gotta stay
and eat you can't just come in and pick
up the knife and go you gotta stay you
gotta have a meal you gotta eat so they
sit down they're having this late-night
meal and as they're sitting around and
having a conversation late at night
the conversation turns to this painting
and she it's her painting she painted it
and she passes it around the table and
as they're talking about it Joe Pesci
says what is one of the more memorable
lines in a movie filled with memorable
lines and I have a clip of that third
30-second clip of that what he says in
this particular scene here's what he
says listen my painting what do you want
from me all right so if you haven't seen
it Elyse you have a teaser now like the
whole movies like this it's fantastic
you never left see it look he says I
just won dogs going one way one that's
going the other way and he got this kind
of middle said hey what do you want from
me
right I'm from New Jersey by the way I
can talk like that and look what does
this have to do with software
development you might be asking yourself
well first of all that's not my
presentation I'm sure what's happening
there but that's fantast op and it's
lovely it's not really clear what
happened to my it's back now so you
might be asking yourself what does that
have to do with software develop so I
was working with a client of mine a
client uh in in the u.s. happened to be
a bank in this particular case it's a
big bank and I was dealing with one of
their transformation managers you know
all the banks are transforming these
days they're all becoming digital
companies right and I was talking to my
client and he was he was in charge of
transforming his cross-functional
development team into a modern software
product development team and he said
look I'm teaching my tech guys agile I
got one guy one dog going one way right
I'm teaching my product folks lean and
lean startup in the enterprise
going the other way right now in his
particular case yeah she had a third dog
yet his design team design teams go in
third ways like I'm teaching them design
thinking and this magical synthesis this
nexus of process and collaboration and
shared understanding and language and
and amazing product success isn't
happening they don't have a shared
language they don't know how to work
together they have different rhythms
different Cadence's and they're not you
know that this this amazing burst of
creativity collaboration agility isn't
working and I'm here in the middle said
hey what do you want from me
I trained everybody and all the modern
stuff right I got agile training I got
product management training I got
designer design thinking training and
it's just not coming together and I
can't figure out why this really got me
thinking to understand because again you
know in all respects he's doing all the
right things
in this particular case right and it got
me really thinking about the problems
that he was trying to solve and what he
was doing in this case and what I see
happening in a lot of the organizations
that I work with is this is that we try
to fix everything with process right
we've got this these process hammers
right the agile process hammer it
doesn't work hit it with the agile
hammer right doesn't work hit it with
the lean or the Lean Startup hammer I've
designed thinking we got a design
thinking hammer now let's just hit it
with the design thinking hammer and and
hope that it will make things better
right we have this sense that if we just
apply the right amount of process
everything will start to work better
than be better collaborations better
conversations with the ultimate goal of
building better software for our
customers and the reality is that this
isn't true so how do we get around this
now as I was thinking about this it
dawned on me that startups don't have
this problem right
startups generally have a small amount
of people right and so there's no real
deep discussion about are we agile are
we lean are we gonna use design thinking
right everybody's working very quickly
to make sure that we don't run out of
runway because if we make enough wrong
decisions enough times we will run out
of runway and we will go out of business
but some startups get lucky and they
find product market fit
and they scale and they grow to become
larger and larger and larger companies
and as the companies grow we have more
options with more choices because we
have more money first of all we can hire
specialists whereas before we could hire
somebody who maybe could do two jobs now
we can hire individuals right we can
build larger teams and it feels like we
have seemingly endless runway like we
can just keep going forever because
generally speaking as the companies get
larger and larger and larger if you make
enough must if you make mistakes nothing
really happens very rarely to someone
actually get fired even in the United
States right it doesn't really happen if
someone gets fired for making a big
mistake and and most importantly larger
organizations assume they already know
everything we're big or successful we're
the market leader right why do we have
to you know to do anything differently
at this point look how big and
successful and market leading we are
right and yet and yet in all of my
travels and I work with companies around
the world I see this all the time these
talking heads we want to be lean we want
to be agile we want to recapture that
innovative spirit we had as a start-up
we seem to have lost the speed the time
to market I don't have that phrase
resonates with you right how do we
recapture that how do we bring that
together and the interesting thing is
that if you read the material on lean
and agile Design Thinking it seems to
focus on a single team right here's how
you make your team agile here's how you
make your team lean or apply Design
Thinking to a team but when you take
those processes and you stretch them to
larger and larger and larger
organizations to more teams five teams
15 50 500 teams they seem to break and
so the question is why so to answer the
question why I did some scientific
research and my scientific research I
mean I asked Twitter that's it I just
posed the question to Twitter that was
the extent of my scientific research and
these were the answers that came back
these were the themes that came back
from my scientific research exercise my
Twitter research exercise right these
were the themes and these are to be
clear I got a lot more answers than this
but these are the themes that I see
consistently
with every organization that I work with
right we already know what we need to do
why do we need to waste time learning
again we're big we're successful or
market-leading let's just ship more
software process everything has a
process eighty-five approvals and a
mysterious VAE that block anything
that's not the old way of working that
seems to be a big deal particularly in
larger organizations lots of upfront
planning if we don't write an 85 page
business case for this thing no one's
going to approve it or fund it so we
have to in and then we have to live and
die by the numbers that we put in that
business case and by the date that we
put in that case as well silos rights
and no collaborations developers not
talking to designers designers not
talking to product managers and so forth
valuing business need over user need and
not realizing they're the same thing so
short-term gains right not actually
thinking about who's the customer what
are we trying to make how are you trying
to make them successful and then lastly
worrying about our brand right that
seems to keep companies away from these
agile and lean practices it's scale
because there's an expectation of a
level of service and if we put out
lighter weight less functional products
maybe less polished products that may
damage the brand and we don't want to do
that now the interesting thing is that
when I started down this path there
wasn't a lot of material about agile as
I told you it was kind of its scale it
was focused on on individual teams but
today as you start to look and to try to
out there if you're any kind of a
leadership is team leadership position
or organizational leadership position
and you're trying to figure out how to
build this collaboration and how to
build as collaboration and scale there's
no shortage of recipes out there
everybody's out there trying to sell you
some kind of a framework that will allow
you to then scale these practices and
build that kind of collaboration and
perhaps there's no better better
visualization of that framework of those
options than this chart now look this
chart is terrible and in fact the first
time I saw this chart I felt like this
right and you should too look this chart
is terrible not because of the aesthetic
choices that this designer of this our
consultant made now look by the way if
you haven't seen this before
what this is is well it says it it's the
agile landscape version three by the way
so maybe there's a version four he
caught a lot of crap on Twitter for this
particular chart but look an unjustly so
I believe this is a terrible chart not
because of the aesthetic choices so
what's happening here if you can't see
it every one of the stops on this London
Tube map style illustration is a
technique that's broadly discussed or
used in the agile world everything is on
your scrum extreme programming Kanban
five wise design sprints spikes
literally everything everything is on
here right now the reason why this is a
terrible chart is not because of the
aesthetic choices that this consultant
made it's because it's true right these
are your options you try to build a
better collaboration like my client
right he went out into the world and
he's like okay here all my choices I
chose the three things that seem to be
the most relevant the most popular and I
tried to put them together and it didn't
work right and so the question that
become is how do we get away from this
right and into a more tangible practical
way of building better collaborations
between software developers designers
product managers and ultimately building
better products and services for the
people that we service okay so let's
talk about this for just a second so
what's a jewelry about it's not gonna be
a crash course in agile like I promise
you does that me geez sorry let's not do
that again
agile was conceived by seventeen
software engineers on a mountain in Utah
at high altitude where the air was thin
17 years ago as a bid to you know to
overcome this frustration that they had
with software development it was
unpredictable it was complex it was
difficult to meet customer needs it was
difficult to predict budgets and
deadlines and they figured there had to
be a better way and so at the end of
that long weekend on the mountaintop
they descended biblically from the
mountain giving us the agile manifesto
now the agile manifesto if you've read
it and it's sure
you should read it it doesn't say things
in there like you will stand up every
day at 9:15 for 15 minutes right none of
that crap is in there right it really
doesn't it doesn't it's a philosophy for
work it really isn't it's a good one
overall and perhaps the most important
part is this piece they're just saying
look software development is complex and
unpredictable okay as you start to build
stuff you will learn new things or new
things will happen in the world as you
discover that change if it shifts the
plan that you originally made for the
product that you're building change
course that's it
that's agility in a nutshell like we
could end the session here you can go
home and say I learned what agile is it
or a def right but that's literally it
you make a plan you start to work and as
you discover new things if they disagree
with your plan you change the plan
that's all these guys we're saying is
that we work differently and yet what's
happened is that most organizations have
taken the agile process and they've
productized it and they bring it in and
they hire it for a different purpose not
for agility right not for responsiveness
but to create more high quality code
faster that's why most organization to
bring it for productivity for efficiency
right that's why most organizations
bring in agile right because there's
this belief right that this is what
software engineers have to be doing all
day long right literally there's it can
be no break if a software engineer steps
away from their keyboard at any given
moment right bad stuffs gonna happen
really bad stuff and why right why
because this is what we care about
making the software right velocity
that's what we optimize for that's what
that's what's happening right the spirit
was learning agility responsiveness the
reality is this let's crank out features
right high quality features as fast as
we can and there's this belief that the
more features we make the more value we
deliver right and that's one of the
things we have to get away from right
because the reality is this just because
you can build it does not mean that you
should for example the airplane that got
me here has
and fewer wings than this airplane and
it worked just fine right to get here as
well so that's that's you know start to
think about agile that's kind of where
we end up let's talk about lean for a
second lean is fantastic in that lean if
you take it again in spirit I'm gonna
give you a 30-second conversation around
lean you know there are volumes like
this thick on it so forgive me if I cut
this short
right but basically the the guys at
Toyota we're struggling with a
production and quality issue right they
were dealing with a post-world War two
Japan when you've got the American car
manufacturers like GM and Ford producing
tons and tons and tons of cars Toyota
says look we can't compete on quantity
so we are going to compete on quality
efficiency and variety and to do that we
are going to completely turn the
manufacturing process on its head now
what they're doing here is they're
saying look traditionally car
manufacturing is a push process push
means we're just gonna make a product
and push it onto the market and hope
that people use it we can't afford that
because if we make stuff that people
don't buy or don't use we go out of
business so they turn it on its head
they say look we're gonna make a pull
model a pull model simply says we're
going to look for signals from the
market that tell us what to make when to
make it where to make it and how much of
it to make and then we're only gonna do
that and all that stuff in the middle is
waste we're gonna minimize that because
we can't afford it and along the way
we're gonna trust our people the people
who make the product the people closest
to the product to make the tactical
day-to-day decisions because they're the
closest of the product they have the the
the most feedback the most understanding
of what's happening here we're going to
empower them to make those decisions
that's what lean does and what and the
amazing part here is that lean if you if
you started to try to combine lean and
agile together it should put a brain on
that agile delivery process because it
infuses this concept that you can't
predict the future
right that's what Lean Thinking is about
it's about we're moving from that
position of doubt to a position of
certainty always and to reduce the risk
of going too far in the wrong direction
we work in small batches Sprint's
iterations short cycles help us get
there and move forward more quickly and
so we've got that now Eric Ries did a
nice job in 2011 by talking about this
in Lean Startup he said look start
asking yourselves for everything that
you're working on not can we build it
but should we build it right do
customers want it will they pay for it
and if so terrific then we can try to
scale it and build a business around it
and we can run experiments to learn this
the problem with Lean Startup
particularly in high-growth companies
and large companies is that nobody wants
to buy experiments they want to buy apps
they want to buy systems and so we're
dealing with that now the last thing
before we start to solve all this stuff
is Design Thinking right super popular
digging a lot of companies this is what
most people think it is can't do design
thinking without the post-it notes some
people think it's this crime we lock
ourselves in a room for a week generate
some creativity it's not any of these
things it's this it's simply saying look
designers have some tools for solving
design problems let's take those same
tools and apply them to business
problems right and this stuff should
sound familiar to you if you know
anything about sort of the core
principles of agility and the core
principles of Lean Startup like we want
to empathize want to understand the
customer what are they trying to do want
to define solutions we want to id8
on those solutions create some some
variations we want to prototype and test
them and then based on what we learn
we're going to baby productize if some
of these things or build them right we
talked a lot about that now the nice
thing is that at least two of these
things work well together the design
thinking process fits nicely into the
Lean Startup build measure learn loop
it's the learn piece it's in there right
how do we learn we we do all this
prototyping and that type of thing and
then organizations right try to bring
this in together with the agile piece as
well and this is where it starts to
really struggle because we're trying to
mesh these three processes together that
have different languages and different
Cadence's and different measures of
success this is where my
client was ultimately struggling at best
this is what I've seen customers do they
built some kind of a Frankenstein
process that is you know kind of works
and is kind of weird and awkward and
make some weird noises right but doesn't
really function to the best possible
ability so the question is how do we
bring these things together well most
importantly we need to integrate the
principles of these ideas not the
processes try to layer these processes
on top of each other ends up in that
Frankenstein situation but the
principles the principles of agility the
principles of Lean Thinking the
principles of design thinking work
really well together I want to share
with you ten of those principles in the
time that I have left and tactics for
each of those principles to help you at
least think about this when you go back
to work think about how might we change
the way that we work to apply some of
these principles because this is the way
that we should actually be working if
we're looking to build customer centric
successful services products right and
then ultimately businesses around that
let's start with this one principle
number one customer value and business
value are the same thing it's true you
make your customers successful you
respect their time you help them achieve
their goal but make them better at work
make them better in their home life get
them home to their kids football game on
time right they will reward you they'll
tell their friends they'll tell the
internet they'll tell their boss they'll
buy more stuff from you ignoring
customer value and optimizing for
short-term business value is risky and
can cost you the success of your company
let me show you a recent story Gibson
guitars is out of business you guys know
that it's really sad they went bankrupt
Gibson guitars noticed a shift in the
market place no one was buying guitars
anymore right
drastic drop-off in sales and so they
brought in a new CEO the CEO was all
about innovation right all he wanted to
do was velocity let's make more stuff
more innovative pedals more new
technologies new fancier guitars
integrated with those technologies and
they push that out there and they pushed
all this innovative stuff out there for
the sake of innovation not because any
customer was actually asking
for it and nobody bought it and they
went out of business and they continued
to focus on the things that made them
successful to this point right we're big
we're successful where the market leader
why would we change our approach to our
business and this is what the Gibson
guitar website looks like today now what
they fail to recognize is that yes sales
were dropping off but there were new
buyers coming on and 50% of those new
buyers were women and women generally
speaking don't care about / what they
care about is buying guitars that fit
them guitars that they can play and
learning how to play this is Fender
guitars website fenders thriving they're
doing really well they paid attention to
the market they empathize with their
customers and they're building products
and services that actually meet customer
need they're delivering customer value
and their business is thriving by paying
attention to what's happening in the
marketplace they're adjusting the way
they deliver that value through code
through product through service right
and they're thriving and succeeding and
what they're doing here is they're
taking a user-centered perspective on
the success of their products and
services right not a feature centered
perspective right but a user centered
perspective how are we making our
customers more successful right who are
the customers and what are they trying
to do and what this lens ends up doing
is it changes the definition of done if
we're talking about the agile language
right it changes the definition of done
from output making a thing to outcome
changing customer behavior that's our
new definition of done right did people
buy more stuff did they learn how to
play guitar if so are they coming back
and telling their friends that's what
we're looking at and it's these outcomes
that tell us when we've delivered
customer value and most importantly it's
these outcomes to tell us when we're
done when do we move on to the next
thing when do we stop working on
something right how comes help us and do
that and that's one of the key things to
take away here is that change in
customer behavior is our measure of
success that's our first principle
customer value and business value are
the same thing
principle number two working in short
cycles right upfront planning trying to
predict the future trying to understand
exactly what the software will do when
we're done and how people will use it is
an exercise in frustration and mostly
futility when we do long term product
planning and roadmaps right this is what
we're asking our product development
teams to do this is what we're asking
our software engineers to do our product
managers and our designers they try to
just divine the future right but we
build iterative continuous systems we
don't know what it's gonna look like in
the future and we don't know what the
competition is going to do and we don't
know what our customers are gonna do
with these products and services by
working in shorter cycles we learn more
quickly and I want to be clear by
shorter cycle I mean anything shorter
than what you're doing today so we can
look at the digitally native companies
like Amazon and Google and Facebook and
see how how often and how regularly they
deploy code and that's fantastic for
inspiration but if you work in a bank
and it takes you six months to ship
something today and you can get it down
to three months that's a win right it's
twice as fast as you were before that's
good and our goal with these short
cycles these Sprint's these iterations
is to collect evidence right if we're
moving from doubt to certainty at the
end of every cycle we look back and we
say hey does it still make sense to be
working on this is the feedback from the
market from our data from our team's
from whatever right
this says saying that this is still a
good idea if so you get to take the next
short cycle forward nothing next nine
the next one right and if at any point
at the end of the short cycle we
retrospect we reflect and we say hey are
we still headed in the right direction
are we still making sense right if the
feedback says no this doesn't make sense
anymore then we have to change course
that's agility right that's the thing
that we talked about at the beginning
right shorter cycles means lower
investments means lower risk means it's
easier to change course right and as our
friend the richest man in the world
likes to say the great thing about
fact-based decisions is that they should
overrule the hierarchy right we're
collecting evidence at the end of each
one of these cycles and we try to make
evidence-based decision-making based on
customer
behavior to help you do that let me give
you the two key questions I teach every
team that I work with okay at the end of
every cycle as you're planning your next
cycle ask these two questions okay
first is this what's the next most
important thing we need to learn not
ship learn right that's a that's a very
explicit choice there what's the next
most important thing we need to learn
what's the where's the risk in the thing
that we're building and look sometimes
that's going to be market risk or user
risk or design risk other times it's
going to be technical risk all of those
conversations are important right what's
the next most important thing we need to
learn and then what's the least amount
of work that we need to do to learn that
right how can we do risk this the
fastest so that we don't spend four
cycles or ten cycles to find out that it
we shouldn't have done this I said we
spend one or two max right those are
your experiments does your MVPs right
those are the things that we put out
into market to understand how well we're
going to solve this particular business
problem okay principle number three
retros and I told you that that the
manifesto doesn't have this like you
will stand up every day at 9:15 kind of
stuff but it does talk about retros and
retros are great right retros allow you
to kind of look back on a short time
frame and just talk about hey what
worked well right let's keep doing that
and what didn't work well let's change
that right we talked about there's a
thousand ways to do them right there's
this this is I use this one a lot I
found this one on the internet I like
this one I've done I've done these the
4l4 ELLs retro whatever it takes but the
framework ultimately doesn't matter the
conversation matters right and the
conversation has two purposes for retros
first you're going to make the product
better what did we learn as we shipped
product as we got code into users hands
and what's different about that and then
second we're going to improve the
process
hey last week you know took us forever
to get the designs to the developers
right and by the time they got it there
was no time to implement the design to
its fullest the designers repairs the
developers were pissed what do we do
about that next time
right if that happened for a one week
sprint or a two-week sprint okay right
as long as we tried something different
the next time that happens for ten
sprints in a row retros help you undo
that kind of stuff okay
principle number four go and see right
this is there's all kinds of names for
this going going with the gemba you hear
this from from lean folks right Tom
Peters famous business management guru
talks about managing by walking around
right managing look if you're not a
manager forget that managing buy and
just leave the walking around part right
walk around the office see what other
teams are doing right see what's working
for them right how do they structure
their their meetings their Cadence's
their practices and then amplify the
good patterns bring them to your team if
you manage some teams bring them to
multiple teams and don't worry about the
labels if something works inside your
organization
it makes people productive more
collaborative it builds that shared
language I don't care if it's lean or
agile their design thinking who cares if
it works amplify those patterns and do
that but just walk you'd be amazed
and it's particularly you've got a big
office right what people are doing in
the corners they're building really
interesting practices you can learn from
them and amplify those patterns
principle number five test only your
high-risk hypotheses remember I told you
what do you need to learn first what's
the least amount of work that you need
to do to learn that the least amount of
work you need to do to learn that is
your experiment now look we rarely if
ever have a hundred percent budget for
learning right we have to ship efficient
product bit to ship code how do we test
the most important things that look
hypothesis statements are our best guess
about how we between how we solve a
particularly thorny or risky business
problem for our customers right and so
we believe that we can change behavior
if a specific customer base gets some
kind of a benefit from a feature that we
want to build right if you were to fill
this out it could look something like
this right we believe that a 50%
increase in retention right that's a
change in customer behavior will be
achieved if college students have more
time for school work that's their
benefit right with a food delivery
service from the University cafeteria
right that might be a good idea it might
be a bad idea right but these are our
hypotheses
we're gonna have a lot of these as we
look to build new products and services
for our team but the problem is is you
can't test everything because we have to
ship stuff as well and so I like to use
this framework to focus on which
hypotheses you should actually test how
to focus your learning if we're gonna
build lean thinking design thinking into
our agile processes right we've got to
focus on the most important thing we
need to learn next the hypotheses that
fall into this quadrant the quadrant of
high risk and high perceived value to be
clear it's perceived because you don't
know you think it's a good idea but you
don't know because you can't predict the
future
right and risk again is going to be
contextual might be technically
challenging it might be a business risk
or an adjacent market or whatever it is
the stuff that falls into this top right
corner that's where your learning
activities go that's what your design
thinking your Lean Startup your research
your discovery work right those are the
things those where you apply those
processes right because if something
falls into this bucket high risk low
value just throw it out don't work on
that if something falls in the top left
if you believe it's high value and it's
low risk just build it right the stories
put it in your backlog write the code
ship it right and if your hypotheses
fall down here in the bottom left you
certainly don't need to test them in
most cases you don't even need to build
them there might be some table stakes
stuff stuff that you have to have to run
in your to operate in your market or in
your industry but you certainly don't
need to test that so if you're gonna
build lean lean startup design thinking
UX research into your agile processes
focus it on the high risk high value
hypotheses next one of the most
important things that I've learned in my
career do less more often it's one way
to harness these new process these new
ideas of agile and and again Lean
Startup and so forth into a way that
that everyone can accept regardless of
what they do on your team right so
instead of trying to do a kind of a
massive discovery phase upfront or a big
design phase or a research phase upfront
right we do less we do a much smaller
scale
effort we just do it more regularly
because we've got this time box that
repeats itself every week or every two
weeks right I'll give you an example I
spend a lot of time in the first half of
my career doing traditional research
sitting on the other side of the one-way
mirror eating a lot of candy for two
days and if you ever if you ever done
that I don't if you have but I can tell
you and you know ten people come through
on the first day ten people come through
and they test your product for you on
the second day and I guarantee you that
by the end of the first day you know
everything that the people are gonna say
on the second day right complete waste
of time if you're doing if you're doing
good good work instead right again
coming back to this question what's the
fastest way to learn the next most
important thing and we can run these
experiments based on what do we need to
learn next what's the fastest way to do
that let me show you some examples the
echo in this particular case Amazon
realized that the most important thing
they needed to learn next was what are
people gonna ask this thing and what's a
good answer right voice interface that's
probably good right now look Amazon is
good at writing code and deploying code
and shipping and regularly they could
have just written stuff and seen how it
works instead what they did was they ran
an experiment they did less more often
they built what's called a Wizard of Oz
where they put a customer with a fake
Alexa in one room and a microphone and
the customer would talk to the Alexa and
ask it questions and in the room in an
adjacent room said an engineer with a
laptop and he heard those questions and
he would type those queries into Google
get the answer and then speak those
answers back in a microphone so it feels
like the Alexa is answering your
questions right the reality there's
nothing there they did less and they do
this kind of experiment experimentation
more often they're learning right based
on the most important thing they need to
learn next right here's another great
example I love this example I came
across this just this year yes know
what's happening here
that's right testing self-driving cars
this is Ford Motor Company Ford Motor
Company's been building cars for a
hundred years right
what got them here is not gonna get into
self-driving cars integrated software
integrated Hardware right the most
important thing they needed to learn and
the fastest way that they could do that
was by disguising this guy as a car seat
they put him behind the wheel and then
they put him on the road why right to
learn the next most important thing
which was how will people react to a
self-driving car right because look they
could have written the code they could
have built the hardware they could have
integrated it all and hoped that it
would work but the results here could be
tragic and so instead they did less more
often right they did product discovery
to unto test their highest risk
hypothesis which in this case literally
involved a costume that was it right
again principle number seven working as
a balance team this is the one that gets
broken again and again and again and
again and it's like book after book
after article after blog post after
conference talk talks about this and it
still happens so rarely teams successful
modern software development teams are
small six to ten people okay smaller
teams are more accountable they're more
agile they move more quickly there's no
hiding in a small team okay successful
modern product teams are dedicated they
work on one thing at a time not three
everybody on the team works on one thing
at a time some reason it some reason
organizations across the world seem to
think that its engineers can only work
on one thing at a time but designers and
product managers can support multiple
projects at the same time dedicated
teams much more successful co-located
ideally I know the previous session was
about remote teams right and I recognize
that this is our reality today
co-located is best if you're not
co-located then use the tools that you
learned about in the last session but in
all in order for the
tools to work you have to be awake at
the same time right so that's the key
here if you're not co-located
overlapping time zones okay
cross-functional teams all right all too
often I hear about the developer team
right or the delivery team and the
discovery team right those need to be
the same people product design
engineering working together on the same
thing at the same time it's the only way
that collaboration works otherwise it's
just waterfall we're just handing off to
each other over time any way you slice
it and again just like the lean folks
taught us we want to make our team's
autonomous and empowered if we're
working in short cycles if we're
learning if we're if we're iterating
every week or every two weeks so what if
we get it wrong right we don't need to
micromanage these folks if they make a
mistake they'll find out at the end of
that cycle and they'll course correct
that's the whole point of this way of
working we have to let our teams do
their jobs and make the tactical
day-to-day decisions so they don't have
to run it up 85 approval levels to make
that happen and it's amazing what
happens this is when you do that I am
this is an award that I got in the early
2000s from my team I worked on a browser
at AOL back because we were working
across I was a designer in case you're
wondering still am right I've working
with my engineers and I got a rogue
developer award for inspiring
undocumented creativity and engineers
why because we talked to each other
right and we shared knowledge and we
were on the same team working on things
at the same time so it was a bit of a
joke but again it makes the point three
more things principle number eight one
of the most important things that you
need to be clear about is radical
transparency as an organization how do
you build transparency about what we're
working on why we're working on it how
we're doing and what success looks like
if you can build that into your team's
into your team start with your team and
then scale that out the collaboration is
better people are far more engaged in
making the customer successful and
there's lots of ways to do this rituals
work really particularly well this is
the Karate Kid please how many of you
have seen the Karate Kid all right good
we don't have to explain this one too
much but really quick sobering fact
Ralph Macchio Daniel son he's 50 years
old today hits home a little bit anyway
Daniel son comes to mr. Miyagi says hey
I want to learn karate mr. Miyagi says
that's great
paint the fence he said I want to learn
karate says that's terrific wax my car
unbeknownst to Daniel son he's learning
karate right he's waxing he's getting
emotions right rituals particularly the
scrum the agile rituals work really well
to teach teams transparency if you just
want your team's that be transparent and
be like all right whatever
right stand ups do stand up every day
right that's the beauty of stand ups
they drive transparency the team's might
not know why they're doing stand ups at
first right but it becomes very clear
that if every day you you have to stand
up I have to stand up in front of my
team and I have to say to my team well
yesterday I bought some shoes online
today I'm going to put some money on the
horses and what's getting in my way is
all this work stuff right that
conversation gets really old really fast
right stand ups drive transparency and
what the team is doing a scrum of scrums
demo days demo days are fantastic you
can demo working code you can demo an
experiment that you ran you can demo a
customer conversation it doesn't matter
as long as you're showing the work that
your team is doing drive that
transparency in their access to
customers drives transparency make sure
that you seek it out and that your
company grants it to you right we're
coming up on Black Friday in the United
States this is literally what it looks
like it's actually this coming Friday
it's gonna be fantastic and the reality
is that the more kuffs customer access
that you get the more you can get a
sense of what's actually viable because
of this concept of MVP permeates the way
that we work and we all have a different
version of what minimum actually means
but access to customers tells us is it
actually viable right and that's the key
here is to use that customer feedback to
drive our decision-making and to drive
that home right the other thing that
helps drive transparency in this
particular case is access to data there
was a conversation in the keynote this
morning around
Star Wars or Star Trek I am strongly on
the Star Trek side so you'll see a lot
of that over here but access to data is
key I used to work at a company where
the only way to get any kind of
analytics or reporting was to spend a
certain amount of hours per month in the
biq the business intelligence or
business insights group q right and the
CEO could always jump the queue if he
wanted to so you don't get you report
that month you don't know how your
products are doing right we give our
employees access to electricity and heat
and air conditioning and coffee we give
them access to data everyone should be
able to measure what's happening with
their products so they understand how
things are going that drives
transparency in our decision-making two
more things principle number 9 and this
was tough if you're not in a leadership
position then this one's tough but it's
a good it's a good question to ask right
what are the incentives that we have as
software developers right product
managers or designers as team members
what's the incentive that we have
because it really changes right to help
based on the incentive to help us
determine you know what our asses on the
line for right that's the key in all of
this right in other words what are you
getting paid to do every every day at
work are you getting paid to ship
software right or are you getting paid
to deliver customer value because those
are two very very different things right
are you there to create output period
end of story as long as we get the
features out or are you there to make
customers successful right and in most
organizations that are trying to build
this collaboration between lean agile
and design thinking they are asking
their teams to deliver customer value
and they're paying them to deliver
features and those are two contradictory
things and that's where a lot of this
stuff breaks down so if you're not in a
leadership position I would ask this
question I would I would review it and I
would bring this up with your leaders
and your managers to understand what's
driving the way that we get paid and
what we're being asked to do because
that's often where a lot of this
conflict lasts okay
last principle is this the only way that
these these ideas of lean agile Design
Thinking work well together is if we
make learning a first-class citizen of
our backlog
I've worked in too many organizations
where we've got sort of the real work
backlog which is all dev work and then
design product management research
product discovery all was over here
right and the teams coming in to work
and they've got at least two backlogs
with number one priorities on them to
choose from
guess which one they're picking from
every single time the dev work every
single time right we've got to unify the
work into one place and learning has to
be a part of that
right and look lots of ways to do this
the easiest thing to do is just to track
it to visualize it the same exact way
that you track every other piece of work
right you make cards virtual physical
whatever cards for the dev work do it
for the learning work as well write down
your hypotheses write down how you're
gonna do that learning right what's
what's the experiment what's the what's
the MVP that we're gonna build assign it
to someone and if you're going to
estimate and I'm not opening up that can
of worms ever right that's your choice
but if you're going to estimate all
right put that on there and then once
you've done that put it in your backlog
the same backlog where everything else
goes right explicitly prioritize the
learning work against the delivery work
because there's complicated there's
implications to this right anything that
comes downstream from the learning work
is inherently at greater risk then the
things that come above it and that's
okay let's talk about that and if we
learn something from our learning our
discovery activity right there Design
Thinking or lean startup activity that
changes the downstream prioritization of
our work that's okay
that's agility and that's the whole
point of trying to build this new way of
working and so to kind of summarize all
of this together these are the
principles that I covered and they work
with any methodology right you can take
the practices that work for you but if
you embody these principles you start to
build cross-functional collaborative
teams that focus on customer value and
ultimately deliver great products and
services right and I appreciate you
listening today and I will say thank you
very much
[Applause]